[Music]
hello there and welcome to episode
number 173 of the weekly Google Cobb
platformer podcast I'm mark and I'm here
with Michelle hello Michelle
hi mark how's it going how are you at
least you're going I'm doing well I'm
not staying well I'm doing well I'm
really excited about our topic today
okay what is our topic today we're
talking cloud run we had an
action-packed week last week we were
very busy at cloud next the show kept us
running on our feet all week long
but we have something really exciting to
share with you today it's news that
we've been sitting on for months and
we're very excited to be able to talk
about it yeah I think there's a lot of
buzz about cloud run and I think that
was kind of one of the major
announcements out there it's something
that people have been asking for right
because Google has all these different
service offerings but there was none
that kind of just fit that real nice
point that cloud run comes in - which is
like I've got a container I want to make
it in the cloud go host things BAM cloud
run just does that yeah that's right so
this is a gap that people have been
asking about for a long time and we
finally have all the details for you so
we're gonna talk about that in just a
second but before that we've got to talk
about the cool thing of the week
[Applause]
only one thing mark well if we had to
make it one thing why not make it a list
of a hundred thirty two things I like
your style there was an announcement
that listed all of the cool things but
we'll just cover a couple of them if you
want to go into detail you can but we'll
just talk about our favorites yeah I
think that if you want to click through
the link which will be in the
description it talks about basically all
the cool things that got announced a lot
of product announcements a lot of
additions to existing products a lot of
expanded feature sets you know I'd like
to talk about network service tiers
which is really cool for people who you
know kind of want to put a little bit
more customization into their projects
because typically speaking you know
Google has this ultra-high fast network
and that's great and you know it's super
super good but at the same time a lot of
people don't actually take usage of that
speed right there when every millisecond
counts you want to make sure that you
use that premium tier but what happens
if you're not as concerned if something
gets there in a couple of seconds or
whatever right that's where you can use
the new standard tier to just kind of
jump in and the key part here is the
standard tiers cheaper right so now you
actually have flexibility to say okay
well let's put the projects that aren't
mission-critical or the ones that are
just development projects let's put
those on standards here so we can
actually save a little bit of money and
then I kind of just have that better
optimization to be like do I want to pay
for better performance or go with the
standard performance yeah nice so that's
the backbone for a lot of the services
that we run so it's good to have
different options for people to choose
from one of my favorite announcements
was cloud code or we demoed this we got
to see this up on the keynote stage
during the developer keynote this is
something that I got to try out about a
month or so ago and I absolutely loved
it because it's essentially an IDE for
developing code on kubernetes
it cuts out a lot of the manual steps
and automates a lot of those tasks for
you I really love cloud code I love what
that team has done for us we had a
couple of other exciting announcements
many cool things many cool things I'm
also really happy to hear that cloud
sequel now supports Postgres 11 just
last week so I gave a session at next
last week and in my demo I showed off
Postgres v9 and no idea that V 11 will
be available so that's especially
exciting a couple of other things
I really liked cloud data fusion it's a
GUI for running ETL pipeline so
completely code free it's a way of
integrating with a lot of different
types of data stores and you don't need
a whole lot of expertise this reminds me
of my days as a data engineer if you
haven't tried that check it out if you
do any type of ETL or data engineering
there were also a lot of exciting
developments in the cloud e I platform
space there were quite a few sessions
there was one on using deep learning
images we check out my session it was on
using cube flow quite a few things part
of the AI platform one of them that I
really liked was oto mo natural language
which brings me back to my days as a
startup where we tried to build
something similar now we have a solution
that one lets you do without having to
know a whole lot about data science or
machine learning it's an API that you
can call and get predictions about your
text data a few other exciting
these are G suite add-ins I thought
these were especially interesting so
Google Voice for G suite that means your
your business accounts you can have a
phone number from anywhere that you can
access your G suite account and also
hangouts chat from Gmail so if you are a
G suite user you have those two nice
things waiting for you okay one more
cool thing okay so this is one of the
cloudy i platform announcements this is
actually use as an open source
announcement cube flow released it's
0.50 released last week so that's out on
github you can find it if you were a
previous cube flow user this one has a
ton of changes and I promise that you'll
like them really nice UI changes a lot
of pipeline's features and a ton of
enterprise support so that's something
that I've personally been working on
very hard and I'll lead up to next so
I'm especially excited to see that out
in the open so one extra cool thing
among a lot of smaller cool things
definitely check out that blog post I
think you'll see a kind of a cool
highlight list of all the different
product announcements again those
feature releases a lot of cool stuff
they're definitely worth checking out
but since we're here to talk about cloud
run why don't
go ahead and dive right into the
interview sounds great
[Music]
I'm here with steering and Ryan they're
gonna be talking about Google cloud 1 hi
i'm stearin i'm a product manager on the
service team at google cloud and I'm
Ryan Greg I'm also a product manager on
the service team a Google cloud cool
tell us more about the announcement for
today from the Colorado 30 minutes ago
we announced cloud run something we've
been working on for a very long time now
and we are so excited to release it to
the world and introduce it to everybody
so cloud run basically brings several s2
containers it allows you to run any HTTP
stateless workload on a fully 7s
environment so first things first
can you talk about like what a
serverless mean do we define civiles
with the following characteristics first
and foremost it's an operational model
so you always use a fully managed
infrastructure you always pay for what
you use
and you also have a managed security and
when you think about it with that
definition of surveillance you can
realize that it doesn't apply only to
function as a service it applies to even
more than just compute if you take that
definition and look at something like
firestore which is a several s database
it means those requirements and we
qualify a cloud file store as a service
product for data if we look at several s
compute we can refine a bit more the
definition we can add some development
model on top so when you develop for a
server s compute environment you use
what we call services so it's more
service full than several s actually so
you you develop in terms of services
maybe micro services all of them are
independently scalable and they are
stateless so really they auto scale
based on the needs and more importantly
you only pay for when you use them and
that applies to everything we qualify as
severus including compute when you don't
send any traffic or events to a function
or cloud run service then you just don't
pay anything yeah
google has a history of serverless
products that are out there right be
quite frank says you pay what you use
actually good you can actually go back
you know almost 11 years now to App
Engine you know it wasn't serviced at
the time the word hadn't been coined yet
but you know it really focused on the
idea of just allow the developer to
focus on the code the thing that
actually brings value to their business
and have Google take care of everything
else
so interesting you bring up engine
because one of the people that I know I
always said like it's amazing product
that came out and people at the time did
not give the much value that was due and
I think now we've called run and the
thing is gonna be big you know because
now you can run anything on it any
language right yeah that's right because
we're based on using a docker container
as the artifact that you provide you can
run any language any binary any code
that you can put into a container run
great uncaught rapid esters have put
into their containers even a custom
binary they don't even give us the
source code or anything they compile it
somewhere or maybe even themselves they
got this binary from somebody else and
they run it in a fully service
environment so indeed we've heard from
App Engine customers or cloud function
developers that they were feeling a bit
limited by the available languages so
you know even if it's about a large
variety of languages you always have
this small library that you wish was
available in App Engine you always has
this language that you wish I wish cloud
functions supported that language with
containers you can do anything you can
put any language in a container any
software any binary any library in fact
one of the demos that we're doing here
at next is using OpenOffice in a
container to convert a word document
into a PDF so we've taken you know all
the legacy technology embedded it into
the container and then we can run that
server lessly is pretty cool so it
sounds like there's two different
versions of cloud run that are kind of
announced though what's the difference
between them that's right so there's
cloud run which is the fully managed
hosted service for running service
container
first and there's cotton on gke which
provides many of the same benefits but
actually runs the compute inside your
kubernetes container so you get the same
out of scaling benefits you get the same
URL programming you get the same
container model and the same container
runtime contract but the compute itself
is actually running inside your
kubernetes engine cluster with the same
API is the same CLI the same cloud
console interface being able to deploy
across both of them so you get a great
story for being able to use the platform
that makes the most sense for your
organization whether that's a fully
managed hosted compute product or the
kubernetes product that you may have
already invested in for instance I
already have a legit cluster that I run
some software what kind of scenario
called one would be useful for that to
run in there and not in a managed
service there's a number of different
reasons why you might choose to do this
for one you have a lot more
customization in the types of compute
platform that you're running on so if
you need a bigger CPU or more modern
CPUs that are available on kubernetes
you can have those you can use high
memory nodes in kubernetes so you can
have access to a lot more RAM than what
you'll have on the hosted service it
also lets you run a bunch of different
workloads together on the same computer
so if you have workloads that you've
previously deployed on kubernetes that
you want to have a low latency next two
you can deploy those workloads into your
kubernetes cluster
i'm kubernetes also gives you access to
hardware accelerators GPUs and TPU so if
you have service workloads that want to
take advantage of that hardware
acceleration you can deploy those from
cloud run into kubernetes engine and
access the GPUs as well machine learning
all the things right so I mean it's fair
to say that if you were just kind of
getting started with it you'd probably
want to use the full service one
absolutely if you don't have kubernetes
already or you just want to kick the
tires of cloud run the hosted service is
absolutely the way to go if you're a big
organization that has a big kubernetes
investment and using cloud run and gke
probably make sense and the good thing
is that it's super easy to change your
mind
we have customers who told us oh I
deployed first on the fully managed
version of cloud run because I was
looking for an easy way to get started
but then I realized I was needing to be
close to my gke workload so I moved it
to my cluster but from a developer
perspective they get the exact same
experience the exact same user interface
the exact
same command-line the exact same API
even this whole strategy that we have
with cloud run is really based on what
we've heard from customers who have been
using App Engine cloud functions and
kubernetes engine where you know
sometimes for an IT to Mead or for some
particular reason they want to move what
they have done from App Engine into gke
and in the past that was actually
somewhat difficult you had to think
about how to rebuild the application you
had to learn how to burn a DS worked
there was a lot that went into it both
cloud run and cotton on gke it's
actually just really simple you can just
redeploy the application container into
your kubernetes engine and everything
works just take it and check it over the
wall you're good to go but you know
we're court ability isn't the only thing
that we wanted to focus on with
portability we wanted to make sure that
the skills the developers were building
up while they were using cloud run were
portable as well so that it wasn't just
that you were locked into a service
platform with his knowledge that you
were gaining that you could deploy it
into kubernetes or through the open
source kane ativ project actually into
any kubernetes cluster running anywhere
including an on-premises I think we have
to give a little bit more details here
cloud run and Clara non-ge
both implement the Kay native serving
API which is an open source project we
launched last year at cloud next 2018
and can it've itself you can install it
anywhere kubernetes run so if you think
about it that means that the tooling
that you built around this API is not
only compatible with Quran clarendon GAE
but also with any cognitive
implementation and we have many partners
who are offering managed Kennedy
in their in their cloud platforms that's
how I keep this skill to zero on your
cluster of key native helping yeah
that's right one of the features that
can aid observing offers is the ability
to scale to zero inside the kubernetes
cluster so we don't change the way the
kubernetes cluster is set up that we
don't change the provisioned nodes in
the cluster
but we can scale the instances of a
container down to zero or if you're
familiar with kubernetes the pods in
that cluster down to zero for a workload
and there's another really cool feature
that I think came out this week which is
called gke usage metering which lets you
as an organization see how people are
using the resources inside your
kubernetes cluster and so by combining
cloud run and GK York a native with that
you can actually do a scale to 0 cost
for your internal teams when how you
charge them back for the resources
they're using in your cluster so you've
got this ability down to take these you
know containers fully portable move
around whether it's cube entities hosted
with google kubernetes hosted somewhere
else you can kind of move all these
things around what's the best way that
someone's actually going to start like
managing their build pipelines with this
so of course everybody who thinks
container things darker and darker isn't
an amazing tool to build and push your
docker container there is a very large
ecosystem around docker file if you
don't know what a local file is it's the
very small file that you put to describe
how to build your code into a container
and don't be afraid if you don't know
them take a look at them they are just a
very few lines of code where you start
from a base image down many official
base image like each language community
has official base images hosted on
docker hub and you know you basically
declare what you want to install into
your container so daka files and darker
overall is a industry standout today but
google cloud provides ways to build your
containers in the cloud itself instead
of your local machines or on-premise so
this product is called cloud build so
cloud build will take your sauce and
your darker files and package this up
into a container image fully on demand
so I consider cloud build severus you
don't have to see any servers you pay
only when you build that qualify that
service to me and so cloud build and
cloud run are a good match right you go
from your code to a build artifacts that
you build with cloud build and then you
deploy it to cloud run what's also super
interesting is that cloud build has
cloud build triggers what that means is
that I can decide to trigger a build
when I'm pushing some commits into a git
branch so now we start doing continuous
integration and continuous delivery
because every time the repo
dated that build within the container
and can also as you want
but can also deploy it to plot one I
also add cloudbuilt is the phenomenal
tool for doing builds and doing a
lightweight CI like what starin just
described but the great thing about
using docker containers as the primitive
for deploying compute here is that you
can actually use any CI CD system that
you have already now one of our launch
partners get lab is actually showing off
some of their server list technology
here as well where you can use get lab
to deploy server lessly into cloud run
or 2k native so you can use you know
cloud build if you're if you're starting
from scratch or you can use your
existing CIC D pipelines to flow the
containers straight into cloud run last
week build packs released a beta version
of the pack command line and build packs
allow you to go from source code in your
in various languages directly to
containers without without having to
think about docker files even I really
recommend to check out build packs it's
it's a great match to build containers
when you are a language expert
yeah I have trouble with darker files I
always have to fight them or I'd lose it
and in the insulin helps me yeah the
great thing about the PAC command-line
tool that just got launched is that you
can just type one command inside a
folder with source and it leverages the
build packs to go ahead and create a
docker container for you so if you are a
Java developer I heard that Jim Java
image builder wasn't amazing to you just
import a maven package in your bandit
XML and then in one command you can
build your java app into a container you
don't even need darker installed locally
yeah the jib thing that was a couple
weeks ago I think it was pretty recent
just came out you can easily
you said maven a great I'll put it in
there Phil type line and then BAM in the
same way you're building your containers
without having to worry about all the
little tweaks that you might need to put
in the docker file this is one of the
reasons we're really excited about
having containers as the primitive is
because you know there is so much
tooling in the in such a large ecosystem
built up around talker containers that
you know we just you can use whatever
tools you want to be able to deploy on
to cloud run I never could get past the
docker compose everybody said that was
easier to use but like i sticked with
the darker fire it's i'll gonna check
back i will you commander in the cloud
or in quick start we are giving a very
simple dock of ice in popular languages
for people to get started so if you are
a node.js developer don't be scared the
dock affair is literally five lines from
nodejs npm install and and game starts
that's what it says the cauldron was in
alpha right and now it's in better
correct chorus so what our people are
building on it so we've seen two major
categories of use cases the first one
will be exposing public services to the
internet so a lot of them have been
using cloud one to just build websites
or api's or mobile backends some did
chat boards where you you expose just a
simple endpoint that will reply every
time the request comes in this is all
about public microservices so the great
thing about laron is that it will
automatically scale there is an incoming
request so if your website or api is
popular
no problem lauren scales and if it's not
well no problem either because run
scales down to zero hopefully for the
week we hope but we've also seen a large
amount of use cases around private micro
services so this would be people who are
using cloud run to do a data
transformation or image analysis because
the interesting thing is that cloud run
integrates with pep sub so from pub sub
you can push an event to a cloud run
service entirely privately without
having to expose anything to the
internet and Clutton has a request time
out of 15 minutes that means that for 15
minutes you can process an image convert
a dog to a PDF like we are doing today
during the demo so purple we have an air
bus that you probably all know they are
using cloud on to run inside a container
one of their custom binaries to do image
detection on satellite images completely
in a Savalas way when they don't use it
they don't pay anything it scales to
zero and when they have a lot of images
to process well it scales so fifty
minutes is the time out you said 15 15
one five yeah on cloud one cloning Jiki
can do more yeah we have a little bit
more flexibility on the
Karuna decide to make the time out be
longer but of course it's still based on
it the length of an HTTP request so you
know there's some network stability
issues that you may encounter if you try
to push it too much I'm asking because
I'm functions is five minutes if I
recall six minutes of request you can
push it to nine and then I was trying to
do an ETL on it and that's not a good
idea
cod run will be a much better tool for
doing things like ETL for real data
processing more oh I need to check that
out well speaking of which though so now
we've got cloud run
we've got count functions and of course
we were just talking about App Engine
earlier it's a lot of different
solutions here that cover a lot of space
we know that you know you just kind of
want to container you want to throw it
up there cloud run sounds like the best
way to do it but if someone's hitting
started with all this and someone says
oh you should go serverless great but
now I've got at least three different
compute service options to choose from
what's kind of the best way to guide
them down that path is a decision tree
is there like a couple of quick fixes
what would it make sense there so to
start with I would say you have to ask
yourself which level of abstraction do I
want to be at if you really want to
attach some very small snippet of code
next to your database cloud functions
would be ideal you will just provide a
function to do one thing and it would
scan on-demand built for you you don't
have to deal with containers functions
have a lot of event sources that are not
available in cloud or no app engine so
you can also use function to do HTTP but
more importantly event triggered
functions app engine I think is ideal
for web workloads you know I think has
been designed for the web API or the
website use case or maybe the the web
back-end use case so App Engine is sauce
based so it will support now five or
seven languages very well and you know
you go from your local source code you
hit one command and boom the thing is
deployed you don't you don't see the
containers on that pension fund cloud
run I would say it's anything that fits
the container contract of cloud run so
here your imagination is the limit
we are the contract is that we are going
to send you events or requests on and on
point to your container and then you
handle the rest so cloud on would be for
anything else I would say but the good
news is that the three of them are built
on the same Google cloud service
infrastructure they all share the same
sandbox technology allowing us Google to
run unmodified languages in this attack
and maybe one last thing is that cloud
functions is generally available
appengine is generally available cloud
run literally launched 45 minutes ago so
you know depending on your taste for
race to go to production today I think
you know App Engine or cloud functions
is definitely the right choice but it's
a great option for people who want to
get started may check it out
and they all you know I've been include
functions of fully supported products we
invested a lot into App Engine in the
past year and keep investing you know we
learned many new languages on
second-generation runtimes on App Engine
standard environment and we keep
improving at cloud next a 20-19 we are
announcing the ability to connect to VPC
networks from App Engine which was a
huge demand from our customers so we are
heavily investing in those great
products that's very interesting because
on App Engine
you couldn't connect the private network
so if you wanted to have something
that's private process like let's say
communities cluster that you didn't put
it outside and you have something
processing they were called ran you can
use it now yeah it used to be that
everything had to go over the public
Internet to be able to talk between App
Engine and something else but now with
VPC connect you can actually use the VPC
to do all of that internal network
anything else really cool that you've
seen it next that you're super excited
about we are super excited about
introducing cloud run to the world we've
been holding the announcement for so
long now we've been you know interacting
with servants of alpha testers who gave
us tremendous feedback if they are
listening I really want to thank them
for that
they helped us shape the product they
helped us fix issues and now we are
really very excited to give it to the
world and see what developers will build
with cloud run because you know
arbitrary stateless containers on a
fully serviced environment
I think the imagination is the limit now
you're not restricted about anything so
let's see what people will build with it
yeah and you know you think thousands of
alpha testers that we had which we
really could not have made this product
without I also want to thank the
open-source community behind K native
and we have over 50 different
organizations who have been contributing
their time and energy to make key Native
awesome and Candida biz really the basis
that makes the portability story of
cloud run possible so we're really
excited about all of their contributions
as well it's really good to see like
what all these teams kind of come
together with and like you said this is
a big solution for developers who come
in here and say like I want App Engine
but I went with containers I want
functions but I need a little bit more
oomph behind it and that kind of where
this problem comes in it's where I could
solve and it's really awesome to see
like look this is feedback that you all
have given us and this is what we've
done with it yeah I'm super proud of
quadrant like like Stan said you know
we've been working on this for a little
while and we're really happy to have it
launched today and we're really excited
to see what everybody's gonna use it for
yeah give it a try cloud.google.com
slash run and yeah be you were saying
that you were super excited because you
you knew someone who was working on a
perfect use case for just-in-time
compiler and the popular language that
doesn't have that it was like imagine
putting that in a container I'm excited
to see that happen it started rolling
out a couple days before the big
announcement today and like how quickly
people have picked it up and started
using it and like writing blog posts
about it before we could even comment on
the on the product it's been really neat
to see you know these these very
creative solutions catch and speaking of
creative solutions one of our alpha
tester was running doom the video game
on cloud run so of course because it's
request-based
it was sending one image at a time but
the FPS was quite good actually and so
that means you can run anything
including a soft binary of a video game
in a severest way is really cool too
because with concurrency there are a
whole bunch of people hitting the same
instance at the same time so it's like
80 people playing the game
simultaneously and it just scales right
up for and it just kills it so to be
clear clutter is not a replacement for
Google strata and isn't this is not a
use case
can handle anything but probably not I
think this is more also cherry man
you're not gonna get the 4k 60 frames
per second as you can run any stateless
small cloud on the service environment
and paying for what you use well with
that I want to thank you for being here
talking to us it's anything else that
you wanna talk about that we didn't
cover no give it a try yeah I think just
we can't wait to have your listeners try
it out no in a few click you deploy or
demo container in a few more lines of
code you deploy your own container give
it a try
really I will awesome thanks so much for
joining us thank you thank you
very very cool interview it was a lot of
fun you know Gabby and I we're really
excited to hear more about cloud run
like you said being announced it next
amongst all the other announcements I
think this one was kind of special and a
lot of people are really looking forward
to being able to play around with it and
understand more about what that looks
like in the spectrum of all the
different service offerings so mark if I
wanted to get started how would I go
about playing with it that sounds almost
like a question of the week perhaps
okay well let's answer it as though
we're some kind of question of the week
you know obviously it is come out now it
is in beta so anyone can actually just
go to consult cloud.google.com and just
kind of using your normal GAAP account
go ahead and start playing around with
it
but you might want a little bit more
support in doing that so there are
actually some tutorials that are right
into the documentation if you go to
documentation at the cloud run page and
click on quick starts you can see a
couple of guides there but you can also
go to the code lab site which has a few
actual guided kind of step-by-step
tutorials very similar that let you kind
of walk through those things I hear that
Coursera and quick labs will start to
work on more content there so I'm sure
there'll be more resources out there but
the reality is is that you just need a
container and you're pretty much good to
go using the service part so anyone who
is kind of like even with the bare-bones
docker file you can kind of get an
application up and running in cloud run
within a couple of minutes so they
showed it off on stage and it was very
cool to see how quick and easy it was to
spin up yeah that's right those code
labs that's something that our team
works on we actually author those it's
it's some Googlers the cloud run one was
written by alexis moussine poo chicken
he's one of our colleagues it's it's a
great one and he was working all the way
up until the last minute to make sure
that everyone has access to it so check
it out I hear it's a great experience so
with all of that being said and I know
everyone's still kind of recovering from
next because it was an exhausting week
it was a very long week it was
action-packed there were just so many
announcements and I think Mark and I
both over the weekend just sort of
turtled up and very little got done
except for like mental recuperation
that's a great fancy word for doing
nothing and just trying to stay alive so
where do we go from here what are we
doing this week where will we all be
well right now of course we're recording
this podcast as a lot of our colleagues
are out traveling right so gabby is over
at PI Texas you know John and Mark are
actually over at the with the East Coast
gaming conference right yeah so they'll
be out there you and I and probably
everyone else will actually be going to
Google i/o that's coming up in a couple
of weeks that's right
and then you're going to somewhere very
fancy in May right yes I'll be at cube
con Barcelona with a few of the other
cute flow folks sounds exciting
it is I'm just plenty much
now I'm a little bit behind because of
all of the next work with all that I'm
gonna take some time off maybe lie low
for a little bit and then obviously get
back up for I out coming up yeah so if
you're in the Bay Area the first week of
May or the second week of May I believe
join us for Google i/o mark and I will
both be there along with a number of our
other colleagues
it'll be hopefully a little less than
next a little less extra the next was I
think so
we're not primarily responsible for this
conference which helps but I will be at
the code labs booth so if you want to do
more of those hands-on walkthroughs you
could do the cloud run walkthroughs
there's a whole host of brand-new code
labs for you to try out at Google i/o oh
and I forgot to totally mention that
like all the Google cloud next stuff is
also on YouTube so like if you couldn't
make it out there be sure to go to
youtube and check out the videos there
in case you want to recap on a couple of
cool sessions and then you know I'm sure
that after i/o will probably have some
some content going up there as well
you'll see mark merch and Donny's face
on a lot of those videos he was involved
in quite a bit of video production time
and a few of our other colleagues and
you'll see any of the sessions that you
didn't get to see in person you can find
most of those recordings up there very
cool
all right well we'll let everyone go
thanks everyone for listening and we'll
see you all next week
thanks see ya
[Music]